It doesn't really make any sense, but okay. Because their council's
claim was that I was the one that was personally harassing and
intimidating people. And if you file under seal, I still get
the name. So theoretically, I would still be able to harass people.
But so the whole point here is to pretend that he's he's like
not done anything. Um when when he clearly So here's the game
that's being played. Here's what he does. He goes on his stream.
He talks about the court case. He says Pixie's legal name. He's
a fame supreme. He smears loner box. He does all these things,
all these little things that are designed to throw bits to his
audience to keep it going, to keep the ball rolling, to keep
the pressure on these people. Right now, he's saying, "Well,
I don't harass them. How's it harassment to just say someone's
name on stream?" That that's basically what he's saying. Well,
I'm not harassing them. I'm not intimidating the witnesses.
That's just, oh, well, just cuz I said their name and some random
person goes and does something that's me harassing them. Yes,
because you know exactly what you're doing when you get on your
stream and say a legal name that they don't use and instead use
a screen name. You know exactly what you're doing. Yes. You think
a court is too [__] to figure this out, Destiny?
You really get a court is too [__] dumb to figure
out that when you get on your live stream and say negative things
about someone using their legal name to 10,000 plus people live
and over 100,000 on VODs. You think the court is so [__]
stupid they can't look at that and go, "Oh, it I think he might
be I think he might be maliciously playing the edges of the system
here. I think he might be maliciously finding the exact spot
in the rules where he feels safe to to exact punishment on the
people that are coming against. You really think a court's that
[__] stupid? Do you think they're as dumb as your
average [__] chat? You think they're as stupid as
Metaloid Sword? They aren't.